three three one let's go next to our
caller from the three three one area
code who's this hello good afternoon
three three one area code my name is
Curtis pawn from Chicago though all
right go ahead Curtis afternoon actually
thank you so I wanted to get your
thoughts on something David we have the
Russia collusion investigation going on
to trump and everything we do however it
seems given what we know about Deutsche
Bank and those relevant ties and you
know the shady financial deals what have
you yeah I think that perhaps it's not
so much Russia collusion as it is shady
business deals and practices in a form
of crime that Russians are just you know
very well populated in yeah so there's
you know you're writing the person here
yep I'm sorry no there's basically three
parts of the investigation okay
there is the initial to what extent was
there a coordination contact collusion
between Trump or associates and known or
unknown to the Trump associates Russian
individuals that's number one number two
is does the reaction to that which
includes the firing of James Comey
Andrew McCabe all of the other stuff
does that constitute any criminality
obstruction of justice if multiple
people knew about it could be conspiracy
to defraud that's a whole other thing
and remember three is all the financial
stuff potential money-laundering through
the sale the purchase and then sale at
artificially inflated prices of Russian
of condos to Russian oligarchs the
Deutsche Bank's all of it yeah so those
that's one of the three avenues of the
investigation and then since your system
is call me there yeah another thing I
want to kind of you know a pine on and
get your opinion on as well as you know
I mr. Comey is unassailable by a person
like Donald Trump especially in terms of
credibility yet the tweets from James
Comey some of them
you know had a slight gloating nature
somewhat mocking very mild in a way and
you know it does somewhat upset me who
am i but it doesn't accept me because it
only serves to give that little more of
an ember of a flame yeah to the lunatic
of the excuse me the lunatics of the
Trump base you know they believe it's
all a hoax created by the Democrats and
and then you have Comey like you know
with a little poking and prodding with
yeah just serves to fire them up it's
very small and minor thing but you know
he take a contemporaneous notes with any
globe from tweet you know no I don't
disagree with you I actually think I
would only put I would have rather not
seen James Comey sent thank you for the
call by the way I would have rather seen
James Comey not take not tweet those
things even though as as is being
pointed out they were only slightly
snarky but I think that anything that
could keep him out of even possible
criticism I would have preferred to see
listen I still think that the guy
generally speaking is credible his
contemporaneous notes I believe are
credible but I agree I would have rather
him just wait and we hear from him in
sort of a more formal setting with his
official comments that's my opinion
you're gonna hate the next few weeks
because he's on a book tour yeah right
and a lot of it could be could be based
on that but you what do you think oh it
certainly doesn't undermine his
credibility you know or just the
question about style it's the same thing
about when he decided not to press
charges or recommend charges against
Hillary Clinton he had to give a press
conference about it how did you say that
who goes dormer yeah because the only
reason I knew about him before any of
this was because during the George W
Bush administration he was the one that
stopped the warrantless wiretap program
from being Stein by like going into
Ashcroft hospital room like that takes
some chutzpah yes and so for this guy to
be released by Donald Trump in the way
that he was I'm sure there's some
personal animosity there yeah and I'm
not surprised he's expressing it a
little bit duck so he doesn't bother me
at all yeah I want there you go so
everybody will make of it what they will
and no shortage of hoods but that's for
sure alright that's that's it for today
I I know that we have 15 people holding
I apologize that we didn't get to you
today I promise we will take calls again
someday someday very very soon thanks to
everybody who called in today